Hi
Can you say Good Morning to my brother Hank?
(singing) Good Morning, Good Morning
Yay
Hank, I'm inside of a trailer, like at the movie set, look
look its a real, look there's like a thing
There´s Isaac, he's producing the movie
Hi
So Hank, I'm here on the set of The Fault in Our Stars movie
Intentionally weird angle, so that I don´t give away locations
And woah
I've laughing and crying. I think they think I'm crazy
Because, I can't keep my emotions in check at all.
It's just amazing.
So, like, I can't show you the set--no spoilers!
However, I have had a great day today, like I got to hang out with Shailene and Ansel
The camera comes out and you just dork out
It is on.
Do you really paint miniatures?
Miniature what?
No, I'm sorry. I'm sorry to disappoint you though.
Miniature whats?
Oh, miniature Godzillas
No, I don't paint Godzillas.
That's right Hank, Ansel paints miniatures figurines...
He's one of us!
Man I have to tried some crazy angles to keep the set out of it.
Also I got to hang out with Hazel's mom and dad - I mean in the movie not, they're not real-  It feels real though
Hank what up? We are in Pittsburgh, no we are in (beep)
No, no, we can't give away locations.
Oh no, we are in Indiana
No we are in...
No, no, no we are in Alaska.
And also the screenwriters are here.
Hey what's up?
Hey Hank
Congrats on the Emmy.
Wait a second. "The Lizzie Bennet Diaries" won a freakin Emmy? Congratulations!
So what do I do on set?
Well mostly this: I listen on what's happening on headphones while watching on a monitor
I know this looks very boring, but it's actually amazing to see a story that for a long time existed only in my imagination become visible which is why I'm always laughing and crying.
Like from the Phalanxifor bottles to the costumes.
I just keep saying: Oh my God what is air?
And then, Josh Boone the director is like
-Air is mostly nitrogen and oxygen.
-At which point I say: clearly Josh you are not spending enough time on the internet.
So Hank, this is a really exciting time, but of course it's also kind of a scary time for people who care a lot about the book
which includes me, but it also - and this is important- includes all of the people who are working on this movie, and there are more of a hundred of them.
The Fault in Our Stars movie is happening because of an amazing script and great producers and a wondreful director
And this beautiful, awesome cast.
But it is also happening because of the many people who have read and loved and shared the book so generously.
Make no mistake Hank, if people didn't like the book there would be no movie.
And we all understand that. So please know that everyone here on this set feels a tremendous responsibility to the story and to it's readers.
Ultimately, I think that's why it's going to be a good movie
Oh my God, I think that's poison ivy.
HUGE MISTAKE!
So Nerdfighteria thank you for making my dreams come true.
Hank, congratulations again on your Emmy!
I will see you on Friday